[Music]
so
my
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
can you guys hear me am i being heard
correctly
can you guys hear me
or am i talking to myself what
is going on guys king is uh
isn't root he should be here probably
within the next 10 minutes
trying to make sure you guys can still
hear me am i loud and clear
am i clear and loud
clear and loud that's what i am i'm
clear and loud
what's up nova
i'm yeah i'm definitely talking to
myself man that
so it's what you got to do man i don't
know if you guys know this
but if you want to be
on youtube and twitch you got to know
how to talk to yourself
now what i'm going to try to do i don't
know if if king will be up for this
probably not gonna do it today
and i don't know if king want to do this
but when i do these streams what i would
like to do
is i would like to have both of our cams
on the stream itself would that would
that be something that would be cool
like unfortunately we'd have to go to
like discord or something like that
but i i'd like to have both of our cams
on the screen
of the actual stream but that that's
something that i'm gonna have to
keen gonna have to agree to something i
can't just force on [ __ ]
oh man i can't cuss oh my gosh already
man already messing up already messing
up
cognito leave we go we go we go loose
man we go we lose
ah
got got some sleep last night i feel
okay
supposed to go to the gym this morning
but i had to cancel it because i needed
to work on a youtube video
and then i needed to do this stream at
one
but we go we're gonna get through today
man we're gonna get through today i'm
still
gonna go to the gym just not this early
i usually go to the gym early
let's go ahead and show the screen
show the screen of the it takes two now
i'm going
to lie to you i played like played the
first level with this with kid not even
really the first level
i just kind of beat the first boss
that's like the first 30 minutes of the
game
i mean me king we in for a treat man we
in for a treat what i saw in this game
or what i played at this game
last night they did something special
already man i can already tell i ain't
even played no game
but i could tell they did something
special
did something special
uh now can you guys hear the sound of
the game
i'm gonna i'm gonna stop talking for a
brief moment so you can tell me if you
can hear it
you hear it because i hear it
but doesn't matter what i hear that is
what you hear
there is a brief delay i hate that delay
but there it's there man it's there i'm
waiting i'm waiting to reach the chat
okay good look me
me and uh me and
king might have to fight who's gonna be
the the wife or the or the husband
i don't know who what do you think king
should be the wife or the husband put a
one in the chat for the husband
put a two in the chat for the wife i
will let the chat decide
oh you hear me twice how do you hear me
twice
what how do you hear me twice oh okay
okay okay
i was looking at everything man
so we got a two i'm pretty sure i said
two was the wife
so we got a two we got another two it's
not looking good he might be the wife or
another two
two two two oh
hustle hustle man can he lay he gets
number two he gets
two for being late one
two
well king's technically not late he he
had to do some
some personal stuff this morning so you
know
what's three what's three i'm curious
what three is
curious what three is man i don't know
what three is so i don't think they know
what three is
what's three i want some guesses on what
three can be let's have some imagination
going on in that chat
tell me what three is put it in the chat
what is the option for three
what is three
three equals but he's a book
oh wow
three's a coin flip uh we could do that
but i feel like all the twos in there
will be unjustified
all the twos in there would be
unjustified
if we just let him do a coin flip we'll
see how king feels when he gets in here
and yes i've been playing octopath
traveler you caught me
i've been playing octopus
and yes you guys can attack my white
okay okay
there were people that was clowning my
white interface now this is how it goes
i have it to where whatever time of the
day it is that's what it is so tonight
it will be black
during the day it's white i can't help
that
i guess i could help that i could change
it but i ain't doing that
aaron summers we are talking about
whether or not
king should be the wife or the husband
one
is for the husband two's for the wife
and three is for a coin flip
the lethal boys the lethal weapon boys
why we gotta make everything about race
man
gotta make everything about race
white background you guys are too much
man you guys are too much
i am going to have to watch
my backgrounds around you guys not to
watch my background around you guys
what's up king you
uh can you hear me fine yeah there you
go
okay chad can you hear king is king loud
and clear
am i loud and clear
[Applause]
look waiting for it man waiting for it
you guys always gotta check your goddamn
phone
food when you go to these places man
order these this fish sandwich
all right there's the invite for you but
when you get in here we'll give you a
couple minutes to eat
[Music]
it's a buddy cup i wasn't caught i was
just joking with the clan
they're they're saying that uh they're
like is the lethal uh the lethal weapon
boys the attica king shot i was like oh
everything got to be raised i got you
everything gotta be right
i keep it so so the the chat and i i
did we because uh obviously you have to
play the white for the
or the husband we put a one for you to
play the husband
a two two for you to play the wife or
three we
we flip a coin what do you think one
king
oh the wife
they're no good they know that
i can't hear
can you hear me no i can't hear you okay
i can hear you all right good
someone said hey lords you are both
clear including the crisp packet
someone said two two two
might as well let them go ahead and see
the the intro
the game kind of gives me a um a ways
out
great the uh toaster bro like the girls
used to eat a vegetable
yeah how did it go gonna work with a
tool asset
mm-hmm don't tell me you forgot about
the dentist appointment no i didn't
forget i thought you were taking it
though no it was today
i'm working tomorrow but it's saturday i
know i've got to work overtime
you have to do that every week oh cody
i'm not in the mood for this discussion
again
hey hey rose needs both of us okay
that's not fair using her i'm not using
her i'm just stating a fact
why don't we just rules got some big ass
ears
yeah she hiding those ears in that uh
and that bold haircut
she can hear all of that let's not tell
her
let's stay friends instead yes
let's stay friends forever roses
she's doing voodoo
chase going
it's two voodoo dolls she's linking them
to their souls right now
so what am i uh
i can be the chick no the chat said
you're the chick so i guess we'll go
with the chat
[Laughter]
look the chat always wins unless they
say some suspect stuff then they don't
win
you guys are going to hell
hey honey can i just
take elephant a sec all right
uh rose honey
you know we love you right yeah
and sometimes that means that uh
we have to do stuff that isn't always
very
fun well it's not fun for you but it's
fun for us
yeah this this is kind of like it kind
of intrigued me man i feel like
i shouldn't be here i'm peeking through
the window
yeah i'm gonna feel like a weirdo now
[Music]
can i go do some magic why does she have
an accent but they don't
i know right cause that's not his kiss
that's why they get in the divorce kid
look kind of creepy going up the steps
boy
shout out to the to the uh to the two
super chat
r from rayden blaine going to watch for
a bit how long you uh you playing for
however long i think king got stuff to
do at four so probably like an hour and
a
half
as long as miles morales
man she gonna be an expert at sneaking
out when she gets older
she already she's gonna be able to be
able to sneak out
she got magic she just gonna fly out
blow out the room you have to help me
now they have to stay together
she conjure and experience
crazy it says here love is work
see you have to work on it
you can't just give up hey man i want
that book
if it could turn i don't want nothing to
do with that book i want that book
i want that book
if you could turn people into dolls like
i want that book
be careful what you wish for well i
didn't say i was being turned into a
doll
oh she got some nice teeth
that's what half the budget went to was
in her teeth
so what you got to do is you got to cry
on the dolls
in order for the doll to be real oh my
god
this is voodoo at its finest
[Music]
hey is that you
they can't even have sex because they're
dogs with no junk
i don't know man chuck e chick you look
like a pudding
i know but he was real for a second when
he did it
remember i think that was in the first
one
what have you done what what why do you
always blame me
huh yes why do you always blame
thank you oh oh what is that
i'm dr hockey worldwide
i'm done sonny
[Music]
why you gotta be spanish like spanish is
the masters
to get together again this is definitely
a nightmare
i need to wake up
[Music]
my god you can't wake up here
exactly okay he said exactamente
so uh how do you wake up cody may
just get defeat your relationship we
just fixed it
i'm done we're uh divorcing it's all
good
no i will fix your relationship
that's how the judge be when you want to
get a divorce
i promise your daughter to fix your
marriage
appreciate king posting us on twitter
and said he's watching us shout out to
you
in the mountains like lovebirds you know
what i'm saying
hello hello
how do we get up to her i'm honest the
stairs over there
but we can't reach them we're tiny this
little chick is happening
oh whoa man may uh
they're alive what is going on here i
have no clue
but whatever's going on we can't lower
that staircase
you know what i'm not gonna lie they
were smart
they knew that they couldn't do super
realistic human graphics
so they said yo we go with toy models
the animations was really good from a
way out you know
it was just you know you know some of
the uh the facials
really didn't look all that hey my body
feels weird
because you're made of clay keep your
eyes on the fuses
okay don't you feel weird
you're made of wood what the hell oh
okay same here oh
almost fell off the truck
give me a second
you kind of nimble boy i don't know why
she won't leave that dude
me neither
oh what the hell
come here damn fuse get that fuse grab
it
i am i am we're in the pipes
this fuses more trouble this works
oh yeah three
three two coordinate one
me cody all right all right carry your
fuse
damn refuse oh oh my legs cody
i got it oh thanks thanks eric
i didn't do nothing no
i did it to myself what the hell is this
why would i jump on a saw
maybe that container can help hold up
hold up
wait a minute
come on come on there we go i'm looking
for the dash
i gotta jump up there with you get me
out of here
oh oh don't get electrocuted boys
hey may i need you over here
[Music]
i'm running come here come here
all right
[Laughter]
all right this is the last one let's put
it in
oh perfect let's go yeah
she would be the one to say that
wouldn't she oh yeah
that little mexican book is dangerous
i'm cracked up
happened oh those damn fuses
oh man there she is they weren't playing
rose darling oh no
god not you again we'll move out of the
way you stupid book yeah get out of the
way i need to go and talk to them
they're gonna throw that book away when
they get back
they're gonna find that book never gonna
get that word
why he gotta move his hips like that
[Laughter]
he said i know you're doing oh
[Laughter]
he said he's the forgotten sex toy in
the basement that
caused the dysfunction in the marriage
all kinds of crap in your stomach oh
no that sucks yeah you did it
you you was the one down here losing me
wrong
oh my god pause pause
he got the google eyes i was watching it
yesterday he got the google eyes like
call that
just well i mean you know some of it
it's
so that's why it broke down it was your
fault
oh and you promised him you'd fix me
thank you instead you put me away for
life in here
[Music]
i don't need no appliances coming to
life
that'd be horrible your refrigerator
gets like upset with you
this oh [ __ ] this milk's two days
i'm gonna get back old rose yes you want
to talk to your daughter yes
that was five seconds away from them you
[ __ ] together oh
come on why are you doing that we got to
fight the vacuum king how you feel about
that we gotta fight the
boy he got that butt chad he's not
good all right bye now crazy there's a
bye bye
bye dirty sanchez happened yeah
well this would never have happened if
you had fixed it like you promised well
i didn't know we'd end up in a place
where all vacuum cleaners alive
well now we are maybe we're stuck here
forever
forever no way we're getting a divorce
yeah i know we're getting it
animation looks really good it looks
really
okay let's climb that down vacuum
cleaner oh here we go
you know i don't know how y'all
books are very important to some people
okay forget about the book
oh
[Music]
up there i'll shoot you at it all right
now
you can get off that man
[Music]
oh i fell in the water well you know
what am i supposed to do
maybe i'm supposed to jump over here
okay cool
why didn't you do it oh you too fat
aren't you shut up
i feel attacked
y'all
[Laughter]
see i'm i could do it don't you don't
know me like that
oh i got to throw you up there come here
no you got to come up here
you messed up bro you messed up oh you
trying to stop
we already get a divorce that's fine
[Music]
no wrong one sorry
oh you did it again you i gotta go
what is that
[Music]
that was kind of fun actually
here you go here you go
[Laughter]
don't let go my dude
on god in them here you go buddy
how am i supposed to get you in oh i
gotta mess with this car
nope gotta cancel that oh okay
hold on okay you can't hit the switch
oh oh so we got a running collaboration
okay come here come here come on
okay grab the thing
i'm so fat it's hard to get to it
that was totally worth an electric
yo this is really fun that dude that
gives a little
low-key a little bit of a masochist man
that's worth an electrocution
that's worth an electrocution who says
that
oh man i missed it
i was trying i was trying to do a super
stomp inside of it
well that's probably why you died
[Music]
damn do a superstar superstar you're
gonna
super stomp your straight yourself
straight into the afterlife
no that's what i did the last time but
being that i got this voodoo doll
i'm all right ain't that right mo not me
i'm really enjoying the fan
oh go inside the hole baby i've already
been in them
she got some hips you got some hips it
worked out she threw those hips
now we know where the book got the head
oh how did i catch with the big boy oh
he's big
all right give it a whirl give it a
whirl man
toss them hips around
i'm about to fall off yeah
take it too long you playing too much
to be helped
[Music]
oh
that's nice
switch it up flip it round
turn it up i made it over
yeah let's keep moving
oh you can tell me when you're doing it
[Laughter]
got you it's my turn
okay you got to do it faster than that
you got to go faster than that
i did go fast you didn't even do it
out here
uh
this is going to come out of this
weighing that 10 pounds
oh no no he's uh he's definitely
he's big bone did son
yo what the hell did you do because you
can't double jump off of that
you have to press x after you don't feel
it
yeah i did it oh i i just did it
get me in that oh
see that's how nice i am you saw that
that was nice
come on it's your turn no
i'm supposed to jump on nose
oh god
[Music]
come on now
let's go king blow it get on it get it
go oh
you gotta wait to get to me that stop so
i can jump on it
oh
yeah give a jump on it smash it i'm
inside you're so good
on top of the king okay
not do it again i didn't know which way
i was gonna go
let's get him oh
oh no no i go through this thing
oh talk about dead weight
get down here vacuum
[Music]
have all the balls that you want that's
the ball
missed the bucket i missed the bucket
hey i missed the bucket
i picked the bucket balls in my mouth
pause come on
come on fat boy look man i i i'm
concentrating
all right i got to make sure i'm getting
a hurry that's why they broke up she
kept calling him big boy
i like that body shame
you destroyed my digestion
and you put me away to rot in here no
you will both die no wait i can still
fix you
i can make you work again no more lies
no no no she's right she's an engineer a
really good one you are you're very good
hey thank you are you really gonna
believe that huh
because i would not this dude
is an [ __ ] my real body back i can
fix you
oh is that so then why did you buy the
expensive turbo x2000
huh that sounds like something we
shouldn't be hearing about too
she brought the turbo down that's why
they get
[Music]
[Music]
the okay x 2 000.
[Music]
they're hot so oh grab it
hold on hold on
oh come on man you wasted it look look
it will be okay
you're fine i died
[Music]
i'm going
no no it's fine someone asked me for the
link to the street
you can wait a second
all right all right all right i'm not i
don't i'm not i'm not doing anything
anymore
i still blame that last one please
i'm up top
still blaming that last one we know
who's the engineer
i don't like how you said that
we know who died in this relationship
you died first buddy look i was dying
because i was doing something important
now i'm getting a redemption i'm getting
back to the bottom i'm getting
redemption
all right
good job
i don't
oh god
come here man come here man he stopped
yeah time to finish this plug him up
let's go
you mess with us you lose eyes take your
eyeballs
you do something more hardcore than the
mafia
come on we have to find rose before she
leaves i hope she knows what's happened
to us
she did it she made these dolls she made
these
she's a voodoo witch why did she make
them look like us
i don't know she's starting to realize
that their their daughter
is a little witch
oh they they just confirm that
playstation is shutting the stores down
they just officially confirmed well yeah
that's what they think that's why they
never came out and said it wasn't
you used this place
these dudes are in heavy denim
twisted version of reality hey cody
through here hey big boy hurry up
telling me right right there it's rose
honey what is this creepy little
chucky kid door i don't know it makes me
feel uncomfortable
she's making more dogs i feel like after
this game i need to go get a technic
shot though
what was that from playing in the sword
over here we got that [ __ ] on his back
though i know that
i'll take you there if you help me save
my friends
girlfriends my tool friend he's talking
to you
top of a hammer and i'm the one that's
something wrong with me
yo why is his eye ready
that heartless woman do you know her
well
no he doesn't anyway i heard that
heartless woman got a new job in town
and doesn't have time for our hobbies
anymore
who cares about hobbies do you know how
painful it is to die from
rust it's like burning alive
slowly slowly look at hammer there's
some rust remover spray in that tool
cabinet
we can help save your friends but only
if you can get us to rose over there
okay over there over there okay
now go to that big door over there pull
that nail out
we're gonna need it okay here it goes
whoa how come the mill ain't the last
what really oh
cool we got his hammer in a talking
house
oh god let's go oh we about to get a
cease and desist
i'm the hammer heater now i'm a cracker
over here
i have to go on the other side
oh no no i have to to use the yeah okay
do it again you gonna do it you ready
are you ready
thank you
oh my god i can see why she doesn't want
[Music]
yes yo
um put that nail back i want to go back
to the other side it's
um there's a glass over there we can't
go back glasses
you have to bring that thing up remember
oh man there's nothing over there i
broke those glasses i think no but i
think breaking those glasses probably
give us some achievement
i mean or the jump off maybe it'll spawn
you over there
steady now you you jump
you jump okay
see look thanks
jump off the map and see if it will
spawn you at the beginning of the night
nah
it won't it's gonna spawn me back here
you won't know take a try oh i'm going
off now
see look man it was just just to make
sure
that's awesome
let me see if i hold on to it
no oh you oh okay that's you thank you i
appreciate it
you are an [ __ ] it wasn't close
enough to you
yes it was i would have been able to
dash it hold on tight
there's another nail let's go get it uh
yoo-hoo
still over here hello the bridge please
[Music]
now you got two of them these are my
names
sweet more ammunition
oh can i break them with this no
i don't think i can see you for hold up
i get i think i have to get over there
no try to hit it again
no i'm supposed to do this to you oh
there we go
all right go ahead hit
too high we gotta take to take the one
out of this one
take the one out of this one yeah
it's too low oh well okay
the other one is that it's apex
all right cool
that should be good
i would i would take my nail back but
i'm not doing it this time
you didn't have to i was so afraid that
you were gonna do it
that i jumped anyway
oh man
[Music]
see i think there's an achievement that
you get with this hammer man
no no hey guys tell me in the chat
if y'all got to this point i got an
achievement for busting up all the
glasses there are no relationships
without chances
challenges make you grow what is it with
you can't you just leave us alone
when you're willing to face a challenge
i'm thinking maybe i should do kos
live so remember
yeah i'm thinking about something
i'm going to be spitballing a lot of
stuff with uh sovereign tomorrow
so
challenge win or lose you must do
it together
oh god i feel like well i guess we're
gonna have to
all right you want to give it a try we
haven't got time for this
playstation what do you say he said no
achievements
okay did he bust all the glasses though
did you bust all the glasses
oh god what is this hammer
hit cody with the hammer oh
oh cody oh you won't beat me i'm faster
than a mole
my hammer's faster than that
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there we
you waited for me
that's it
don't blink or you'll miss me winning
you can do a fake one
this is the hardest thing though
oh
for the person with the hammer that's
why i give him two points
ah the sweet sounds of machinery there's
nothing
we got the little nail in there
there's another machine in the way here
cody
go up there
oh [ __ ] oh damn back on the thing
come on big boy
get out of here
this dude
what the heck is that thing looks like
there's a switch for hammer in the
middle
oh god oh god use your hammer to
score at the target to score use your
hammock to target the score
dash hammer my nails are better than
your hand
you wish just you oh you about to win
this one
[Music]
my dog was messing with me
strapped to your damn back pulling your
trigger finger
just giving me carpal tunnel syndrome
i'm about to sue these dudes
[Music]
oh
oh that did not sound good
oh my god my life
don't screw this you just jump off i
don't even know what we're doing yet
cody you gotta just catch it while it's
out yeah just
get the job now
oh okay okay okay hold up thank you i
really appreciate
you no that's got to work
which one do i have to do because like
when you go for this doesn't stop
anything
maybe you gotta hit two oh hold on i got
it
oh i got it i got it
hey
nice one this is platforming at its
finest
[Laughter]
that was on accident that was that
accident
i want to replace them
oh i gotta catch it at the top yeah
there we go
grab that one yeah yeah i could have
grabbed it i pulled back
[Music]
see the whole thing is i got a dash to
[Music]
it
yo oh that's slack
[Music]
oh got it that makes three
oh brother run down no no no no no no no
no no no no no
[Music]
i got you i put you up there you got
scared
oh god i'm afraid oh god don't be afraid
oh okay all right oh great another trust
exercise
what you think you're gonna miss i hope
not
all right get ready to jump on that one
over there
you got you was supposed to pull the
first one i know i i'm still having a
hard time
distinguishing which one i pull out like
like how to pull out one specific one
go okay get ready now
get ready one two
you three i guess i guess it has to work
that way
oh no no no no no no no no hold up
oh yes ready
that one down at the bottom shouldn't be
there no more yeah now we have to start
all over
all right you have to give me a second
to get that back
all right let me know when you got it
ready yep
you know you do have pretty good
teamwork i don't know about that
someone said he working on his pool out
pull our game's crazy
no more babies come on help me break it
open
[Music]
i
[Music]
it's mad nails out here son
oh let's get this grimy
hang in there cool buddies we're coming
to save you
oh he's popping nails on dudes dogs
this is a boss yeah
[Music]
watch out now it's coming above you what
am i
doing you have to wait away from me
watch
what are you hitting what are we doing
here
i don't know i'm looking oh okay okay oh
god i got the future oh you hit it on me
hold up hold up
oh
those things in the sky
[Music]
oh
get ready get ready
this dude is savage he's the savage of
the mean boys
[Music]
get up there get up there
raggedy rush
okay nearly nail it to the wall
here we go here we go here we go
really got him good now get me to the
other side
oh this is nice i like this this is nice
look i don't even i was about to say i
don't have to pay for a lawyer for a dis
divorcing man
look at his face
he needs to stop doing this oh god
oh god he made this way harder than it
has to be
yes it does do local co-op oh maybe
call them all back after you died
[Music]
oh he's doing more
[Music]
heads up
when i called for one all three and then
came back they all came back
ah
watch out
caitlyn says it gets much worse guys i
don't want to hear that
like keep your comments you'll say okay
first off how'd the hammer get there
though she definitely didn't throw it in
that direction
oh
[Music]
god oh god oh god okay
can't we talk about this oh dude i feel
like i'm getting spanked and i'm eight
again
you're definitely out here with the
enemies
[Music]
hold up
let's get
let's do this again man we got this
why is his mouth doing that
all right
i hit it once
oh they're starting to make they're
starting to damage the platform oh my
god
the sword is cutting it open
[Music]
i'm done with these people i'm going
home
[Music]
ah cody we out of here bruh
you got a lot of places to hide
oh let me do it twice that's all
it only let me do it twice it doesn't
let you throw them like simultaneously
here
[Music]
this is crazy
go over there hit her she probably likes
being spanked anyway
[Laughter]
maybe he's the one that likes me maybe
that's that's what their issue was
let me throw the other one there we go
thank god
be kind to your tools brother
oh that felt good to him
that was fun saved us from that rust two
box
thank you may you are a true hero
oh thank you hammer hey what about me
huh i was part of this too where's my
hero love did you see that explosion
anyway we still have to get to rose
oh of course of course sebastian can you
help him out
shout out to lord sovereign with the 20
super chat pure comedy
step on board okay you sure come on it's
safe
okay
what are we doing this time don't worry
knees very precise
the body rumble sling is sebastian
oh wait
[Music]
[Music]
look like a pure robot
help us out oh
you stupid buck oh you've locked us in
you idiot
i thought you wanted to see something
else
[Laughter]
if you stare at the closed door you will
miss the one that's open
okay fyi him in these houses one door in
this shed
and one window good thinking
man whoa the hammer should be punk
husband
you will
[Laughter]
oh yo did you see that no
oh oh jet set radio
oh why dude i feel like this should be
falling off by now
i don't like how you're ahead of me
either ow
what what
bye
i don't think i'm supposed to be down
here
uh chris you gotta get out the chat
brother
hold up we got to start from the last
checkpoint
what happened i was glitched at the bar
on the map
yeah yeah cool but just don't pull
don't worry i'm pretty good at this
this is utterly amazing
oh
oh we have to do it the same like around
the same time
um right there
are you riding the thing when i'm riding
yeah
i can't oh okay yeah yeah
i see i see it
hold up ready do it again come on come
on okay three two one go
he was too early for me
did i get it no all right three
two i had to go a little bit before
after you because mine gets there
quicker
wow
oh that's bull whoa
don't go yet
all right wait wait wait wait wait wait
three two one go
this is cool this is cool i'll give this
this is cool i'm
telling you i i yo they definitely
wanted something
imma tell you this developer understands
what it is to play co-op
what the hell i'm done
[Music]
stick it in pores
what's going on oh no
what's the matter with us zombies
sat down there with her dolls and then
you two
came a knife just like that
you didn't see anything else well there
was one
unusual thing why what happened she was
crying
i know a hundred quiet
sure because i could see her tears
falling onto the dolls
tears were falling onto them yup she
conjured the spell
oh wait a minute i know what happened
it's a spell ridiculous cody we've got
to apply logic
may okay we are having a conversation
with a pair of binoculars
there is no logic in that goodness sake
i don't even believe in spells okay
well did you believe that you could be
turned into a wooden doll huh
he you got a point though glee it had to
be
the tears it was a spell i am telling
you
if it is a spell how do we break it
okay i got this yeah me and rose we read
all about this spell stuff
he taught her right now okay just give
me some space i need to think
he taught her how to do this too
be careful what you're teaching kids if
the spell was cast
through her tears then in order to break
it
oh in order to break it
we have to reverse it
through her tears boom
right okay we basically have to find her
and make her cry on us again oh god
really
this is why she's getting a divorce from
this weirdo i don't know where to find
her miss binoculars
she's in her room
[Applause]
okay thanks uh come on mate
how do we get to a room from here easy
we just climbed the tree
yes oh this we have to go from the shed
to the house we ain't making this
what did this become grounded
at least you can make it to the house
can't make it in the house and ground it
god damn it
come on stupid book throw us the rope
it's too
far
coco shut up shut up and just throw us
the rope
okay okay may relax come on huh
you want the rock you want the rope come
on you want it you wanna come on
oh the book low-key helping us but he's
still he's still an [ __ ]
all right let's swing the cross yeah oh
this game
this line looks nice right
oh look at the ants i like these ants i
don't like the ants and ground
[Music]
i told rose not to throw her shoes up
here oh god her shoes are up here
i did that when i was all types of
things up here i'm looking around
she's outgrown i'm an explorer
yo look at the floor
yo this developer really needs to be
purchased
well ea doesn't really respect i hope he
is respecting this game
did ea produce it or what he made it
that's ea
you know ea respects him if he lets him
do the friend pass thing where only one
of us have to buy it
he ain't letting just anyone do that
he's a genius or other genius
look at the lighting in in the game oh
i'm sorry
hey there's ours to bring this world
live like this used for that thing
let's get across
you got a dash i think we have to use
gravity to to move it a little bit
you just gotta let it move forward by
itself
i i don't see a way to get to rose's
room yet yo why does
this tree have a little
windows like there's elves that live in
here or something
we're gonna figure it out when we get
there
this dude is really five years old
uh you're a clay man with a rope
told you made out of clay man
grab hold
not even close to you may didn't see the
turn points because she was too busy
looking at the leaves
i'm actually enjoying this morning i
enjoyed uh a ways out
well this is more of a lighthearted fun
type of thing you know
a ways out was different plus it was his
first joint
no it's the second dude you know i'm
gonna talk about the ways out was his
first
yeah his first like hardcore co-op game
yeah yeah i don't know he made it called
brothers he made a game called brothers
oh he's the one that did brothers yeah
wow it explains it he he don't miss
yeah damn likely y'all got to be quiet
hey look cody a door a door in a tree
i don't like it we got to get that's
what i said i said the same thing
yes i can see how far away it is that's
why we got to keep moving
maybe there's someone inside you can
help us really
if there's an elf in it i'm telling you
what are you doing we don't know what's
inside there there's a squirrel in there
might be a shortcut
to the house yeah but what if it's not
what if it's
who sent you no one uh
we come in peace we're trying to house
the house
what's your business there we haven't
got time for this is this a shortcut
or not it's a mouse oh god
yo but she missed her hammered out
told you this was a bad idea not helpful
come on help me push
it's too heavy why the glass jar well at
least we can see through it
oh that's great mate we're imprisoned
but the view is amazing
[Laughter]
dad
dad i have to tell you something it's
important
have you heard of this book by dr hakim
he says that it's important to forgive
each other
because then you can become friends
again
if you want you can borrow the book
okay you're busy
sorry she looks weird but
the the hair texture look really really
good
i think the next one they gonna get he's
gonna get faces down but
yo did he tie him up to a chair oh my
god
are you working for the wasps what
the wasps don't play dumb did they send
you here to kill us
well kill you no we're not working for
any
wasps we'll see you scythe i think i did
a tear gasher a
[Applause]
oh god they're just killing us over and
over again we really doing this
boss it doesn't look like they're on the
wasps team
and why don't they die maybe they have
super powers
what if they can help us yeah
let's find out abort
oh you okay yeah you yeah oh just about
that was terrible
you see that yeah we can get you there
really that's very um kind
all one condition
conquest quest follow me
call chris quite
why these tails look like furry bananas
hey mate that's our remote control they
stole it
those sneaky rodents
look our family photos what could they
want with those
i don't know oh you look good
hey that's my underwear
[Music]
don't like streaky underwear pete
the wasps have invaded our tree wiped
out most of our tribe
look how serious this game got all of a
sudden yeah right the tone just went
really deep we can't kill those crazy
creatures you nuts
no no offense don't worry you know just
survived
oh he got a dead eye son he died
[Music]
x200
oh my god
there's one more thing we sent an
undercover agent who could operate our
queen robot
as planned the wasps believed the robot
was their real queen
but instead of wiping out the wasps our
agent was seduced by its power
and switch sides
kill the wasps and the agent in the
robot and we'll help you get to the
house
understood ah yeah sure but
isn't there a more civilized way that we
can
ever feel this about to be some crazy
platforming
i really don't want to have to kill
giant wasps
well you wouldn't have to if you'd
cleaned out the hive
what what hive remember
in the real world in our tree i asked
you so many times and you promised to
get rid of it yeah yeah
fine fine but we wouldn't even be here
if you
hadn't knocked on the squirrel's door
well at least they're gonna lead us to
the house
what are you kidding me you you believe
that i don't trust those squirrels
they stole my underwear oh believe me
that was a blessing
really well at least my underwear is now
a sophisticated part
of a flying machine i sincerely doubt it
can fly
of course you don't we've got to use
that later on you get to the house
i can't wait to get back to my real body
so that we can get divorced oh me too
hey i want to know when this
conversation gonna change from the
divorce
alone don't worry we've got weapons you
mean these homemade squirrel
diy drill passer shanky things
you saw how powerful they are that's
drill bars
these squirrels like to drink shaken
nuts third
what you're listening
yeah this is a warzone
let's try it out
[Music]
archives
this is impressive i'm getting spooky
bye
please turn back
that'll look good
okay you gotta stop i gotta put my
rockets
shoot shoot this down please
are you down there oh yeah shoot it
stop doing that things don't do that
mine does it too thank you no yours just
makes
wait that's what draws this one fat boy
stuff
i don't like that
into the cage can you blow it up
come on come on come on come on oh come
on come on come on
girl come on over to my heart
looks like squirrel attack isn't
foolproof
someone said they made vietnamese
weapons
oh hey it's shooting in the middle he
said they made vietnamese weapons
okay
hit the locks i think blow it up now
hold
maybe we both jump on this we both yeah
oh
okay cool smart man
oh blow it up blow it up blow it up yeah
i'ma blow it up for you
to get you up there
i'm gonna leave you i'm going i'm going
home
okay now you in there now you hit the
trap
now you come over good moves
hey you gotta throw your stuff on this
spot
they're experimenting not this thing
over here really are nuts
look at those tesla coils these
squirrels seem far more capable than i
thought
those bombs oh my god
oh okay hold up go on that
now i got to walk on this little
platform over here but
oh look at this a little bit
now what i got to do is i got to make it
where you can get
i don't think that will work hold up
jump back on the other one
[Music]
[Music]
hey
no let me see let me see what i'm
supposed to do
because even if you make it flat oh
you're supposed to
okay put me on it pop it
uh i gotta i can't pop it
you should be able to shoot no i can't
i got enough to work
so you gotta have to load it up and then
turn it on the other side
now load up the other side the other
side oh yeah okay
i was trying to make that last thing way
more complicated than it was something
else
[Music]
please
hey i wonder what these buttons do
i've always wanted to put you in a cage
wow
give me an acorn why don't you
thank you oh wait you turned me into
acorn
oh
[Music]
hit the stop button
[Music]
i am not gonna let you forget that one
lighten up you look fine
[Music]
megatron
i can't remember what was the blue thing
in power rangers what was that
oh what
is someone in the chat what was the blue
thing that command them in power rangers
what are we supposed to do here oh
come on together one two three
oh we no i have to we have to put it on
each one of these things
now wait till i i put it all around
oh you should have waited a couple more
seconds
yeah spread it around
wait wait for it it's not going away is
it
no no no no no no
looks like something was kept in here
yeah
something big whatever it was it's gone
now
this is that's where they made that uh
that robot be remember
yeah i'm gonna trap it in there
there you go
oh because this is what you're going to
call it so we're going uphill
zordon that's coming
[Music]
oh shoot
oh there's so many of them
dude we being mean to these bees that's
the last
well they're
i would have to get up there so you
could shoot it
hold up
oh no dude fill up that one
let me fill up them both and then you
okay
go on top of it ready yeah jump
fire it up
hey man i think there's a bridge here
let's
knock it down then
how am i supposed to get over
uh there's gotta be something i gotta do
hold up
oh hold on
[Music]
let me
oh
it's time you won one man oh
you think this is gonna be the day oh
that hole
is made for you here we go
[Laughter]
i pull the strings
simple
so i just got that new controller
[Music]
his arms is getting tired
hey big boy get in the hole
what
yeah sorry about that
rose and i used to play with it all the
time that's another thing the squirrels
have taken from us
oh man my legs hurt
my feet hurt when we get out of this
mess
i'm having a cold beer i'm having two
what if we're stuck here oh stuck like
this
you don't know that we'll get to rose
and break the spell
what if we never get to her please stop
talking
and keep running
i feel like we're working for the wrong
people
i think so too
i think uh we're the guardians
working for the whites
[Laughter]
we got to get ready to cut the stream i
gotta get right there
you wanna do one later on today or
uh i gotta finish up some stuff i got in
destiny
some grand night falls
well we definitely gonna finish this
game
yo you know you could use your rope to
pull you
please
what a second what
i was i was following it
and i guess uh trolley was coming behind
me
i'm happy to see keep adding and keep
working on their relationship
my role man a roam calm game
i really love this aspect of it because
i love when you did this in sonic games
and you rolled the rails
oh i saw some stutter yo what was that
about
be with you
turn it
let's put it on the one on top i'm gonna
wait a couple seconds yeah
all right here bees
there's a whole bunch of them
you're gonna get this work little
hornets
together
his back get his back
oh my god
you gotta put a lot on
got it slowing down
[Applause]
let's get through that vault
yes supreme
that is one scary queen
don't worry it's just a squirrel inside
a robot yeah
a very big robot who's trying to kill us
you know maybe we should just turn back
no no no we were just you know exploring
the uh
premises right i think you look scared
like doing little tickets
no not at all you're just scouting
preparing for the mission
yeah right preparation is key good
but remember collaboration is also key
this is a very dangerous operation
sanchez
[Laughter]
as soon as we get to the boss we'll call
it
we're killing the babies
many of uh
[Music]
i forgot my uh grapple hook
so like bionic commando
except for little people
mini bionics
oh these guys can't hurt us
give me a match here
boy
yeah we're here
oh
jesus
i'm back
oh man
yeah when you hit him in the face in the
butt at the same time
it does maximum damage
[Music]
ain't no why for the dead while it's
good this is what the raccoon say
isn't this your cameraman wow
so were the squirrels running away from
something
all right there he
what goes that that was scaring them
oh have to pose quick
oh i got
so oh okay hold on let's do it again you
didn't get this oh
those squirrels have some weird pulls
oh i have to get into frame
i didn't get nothing out of that one
try it again well
look at that
you gotta go back to the other one
you gonna change it how did i change it
oh you gonna change it on this thing all
right good
there we go
well i guess you only get achievements
because i didn't get it crap nothing
man look at the picture
oh we can check it on a wall over here
nice but we'll be better with one of us
in it
nice shot not bad
i should have posed for this one
[Music]
oh god
they call me the exterminators
[Music]
man we're done
come on come on
hit the bumps
oh crap
this is crazy
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
i tried
we gotta do it all over
i think we need to head that way come on
your battery got ain't the time during
the week we'll probably figure out or
sometimes
yeah i can pick up this one o'clock help
me out
yeah this is yeah this is absolutely lit
well
tomorrow know we have a symbol
[Music]
and i got uh sovereign coming over
all right you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh god all right all right we good here
wow the amount of different type of game
play in this game
you just need to see them yeah stagger
you know about gadgets
nature staggering that's not really the
physics the physics involved is crazy
thought that went into this game is
crazy
all right we gotta get out of here all
right i'll see you guys later
all right guys